[Applause]
fantastic thank you thank you I
let's suck it ourselves I know why
you're excited tonight Wyden is in I
know
finally a fresh face and this brings the
number of Democrats running for
president to everybody job made the
announcement on his a social media
platform Western Union you know what I
am gonna I am gonna do old jokes cuz I
do everything kind of jokes it doesn't
mean that I don't think he should be
President
just because he's 76 that's ageism which
is a form of bigotry like the others
okay that but having said that he does
have hair plugs that are older than P
Budaj
three things can be true and I strongly
disagree with those people who say Joe
Biden doesn't have a vision he doesn't
have night vision but no it's it's it's
obvious the woke left is not excited
about this they're like oh great another
white guy in the race so today Joe
announced he is transitioning the woke
people love that but then he [ __ ] up
his own gender pronoun now they hate him
again so now of course the other
complaint about Joe Biden and his
rollout was that it's a light on policy
which is true you know didn't offer
anything like free college but if you
are stressed out about your student
loans who give you a shoulder
now here hey he's brave he went on the
view today all those huggable ladies
it's like sending a drug addict to
Burning Man I mean
but I like Joe's message his message is
different than the other candidate so
far which is there is only one issue
that's what he is saying Donald Trump
must be removed this
this this kind of resonates with me cuz
just as he was saying it this was what
was going on
yeah those to measure what Trump thinks
when he sees this it's like being at a
party seeing your wife talking to your
mistress but but I can tell the Trump is
a little worried about Biden because he
already got a nickname sleepy to sleep
he's attacking biting for being old and
unfit Donald Trump who was built like a
melting porta potti
here's you gotta give it to trump he's
an unbelievable politician that he could
be that an attack he said he said today
I swear to god these are Trump's exact
words I just feel like a young man I'm
so young I can't believe it I'm the
youngest person I am a young vibrant man
he can talk himself into anything well
we'll see how vibrant he is tonight
because it's milania's birthday
[Applause]
well the Trump's do birthdays a little
different she looks like a stripper and
he jumps in the cake no it was lovely
she made a wish and blow out the candles
but he was still there
thanks for that Robert Muller that's the
big that we were off last week for
Easter and that was the big news that we
weren't here for the Muller report the
full one came out and if you haven't
read it spoiler alert
hope dies in the end it was like all the
President's Men meet Al Capone's vault
what the [ __ ] I'm gonna talk about it
this the end but I did not feel good
about this mother report I mean I feel
different about everything round I
learned a lot two weeks ago I thought
laws were almost like rules now I know
if an idiot does it it's not illegal
yeah there was there was no prosecuting
from the prosecutor but he left bread
crumbs because that worked out so well
for Hansel and Gretel
you